bring in former Secretary of State and
author of the new book hell and other
destinations a 21st century memoir
former Secretary of State Madeleine
Albright secretary Albright wonderful to
have you back I see I just want to point
out to everyone you're wearing a brooch
as you usually do what's the
significance of this one well it's a V
and I'll tell you what the significance
is when we were in England during the
war my father broadcast for the BBC and
as a little girl I would listen and they
would always open their broadcast with
the opening of Beethoven's fifth
symphony Dehradun and that was Morse
code for V for victory which is why I
decided to wear a B for victory against
the virus pin I got I gotcha well
there's a lot of concern anger I mean
absolute disgust with China right now
over the corona virus the misinformation
that was provided the disinformation the
propaganda that they're trying now you
are former secretary you were Secretary
of State are you an ambassador I know
you might have different approaches to
this administration but from your
diplomatic expertise so what do you
think the United States should do to
deal with China going forward well first
of all I think that China really does
bear a responsibility for a lot of the
problems at the beginning not having
revealed any information lack of
transparency and that is something that
we have to deal with because I think
that it really did harm the whole
situation and them also kind of trying
to blame us for some things but the
bottom line and is that I think we need
to figure out how to press them now on a
whole series of issues that we need to
cooperate on some on the supply chains
some on the way that we're going to have
to deal internationally with this and
the difficulty I think of being a
diplomat and the trade itself is that
you have to figure out how to compete
with countries tell it like it is and at
the same time try to find areas where
you can cooperate especially in the kind
of a world that we live in now but they
are not going to
avoid responsibility for this their
their lack of information at the
beginning and still their lack of
transparency but I think we now need to
figure out how to solve some of the
current problems that we're having in
terms of supply chain issues and dealing
with this globally you are also a UN
Ambassador and the World Health
Organization which is one of the
agencies within the UN there's
frustration with them as well and for
having taken China at its word and the
Trump administration is saying we're
gonna take a hard look at this what
would you do here would you figure out a
way to have more American influence or
would you consider pulling funding well
I would not consider pulling funding
because I know from the difficulties
when I was up at the UN initially the
Bush administration had not paid up some
of the peacekeeping operations and it
was very hard as we were trying to get
reform to have a voice because if you
are not at the table you're not able to
get the kind of reforms that you need so
I would very much
urge that we understand what the wh o
stands for what we need to do i would
not pull us out of it I think we need to
figure out how much we need to pay but I
think it's a real mistake because you
have no influence over what you need to
do with the UN if you're not at the
table and we wouldn't be at the table
can I ask you about Iran because they
have a big outbreak there trying to see
if they could get out of some of the
sanctions that the Trump administration
has put on them because of their nuclear
weapons program or nuclear program I
should say your thoughts on whether the
United States should relax any of that
well let me just say our sanctions
normally never include issues to do with
food and medicine and I know that that's
one of the issues that's out there I do
think and you won't surprise you when I
say I think it was a mistake but
rillette ministration did offer some
additional support but it was rejected
by the Iranians because we wouldn't
relax on sanctions well and I think that
you know that's their problem that they
rejected it and I but I do think that
the sanctions are a very important tool
but I also do think frankly that we kind
of lost our credibility because of
pulling out of the nuclear agreement
with them so our obviously our
relationship with Iran is very tense I
do think we need to understand their
health issues and we have a very tense
relationship with them and I think that
the sanctions are a good tool if they do
not harm the people and that is one of
the issues for this pandemic coming at
this time during an election year you
have former Vice President Joe Biden
he's now won the endorsement of former
President Obama and he's gonna have to
figure out a way to campaign in this
area and you know China could really be
a big deal and America might be really
frustrated how might you advise him to
thread that needle well I do think I can
just assure you having known senator
Biden and then Vice President Biden is
he is somebody that is very very good at
diplomacy and understanding how to do
something which is to be tough and at
the same time trying to find areas where
we can cooperate as I mentioned earlier
in terms of statecraft it is important
to understand how to be very clear with
what you think and at the same time
understand that you can cooperate and
compete and try to figure out some kind
of a way of working together it is not
kind of thinking that you can give China
pass as I said earlier we need to figure
out what they did and why they didn't do
what they were supposed to but I think
that for everybody's sake we need to
figure out a way to work with them on
the issues to do with the virus and
global health it is very important
because when I cannot do that by
ourselves right back with me now is
former Secretary of State Madeleine
Albright she's got this new book out
today it's called hell and other
destinations a 21st century memoir where
she reflects on approaching the final
stages of one's career and working
productively in your later decades you
write that when you were leaving the
Secretary of State's office interviewers
would ask you how do you want to be
remembered
and you would say I don't want to be
remembered I want to do and you've gone
on to do so much and in this book you
talk about how you are an optimist that
worries a lot and I wondered what are
you worried about the most well I worry
about the fact that we're not getting
all the messages that are out there and
by the way I didn't realize that the
title was going to be so germane at the
moment it was built on something else
but I do think that I am worried that we
are not understanding the solution to
the issues that are out there the
importance of cooperation and the
government the importance of
understanding the overall aspect of the
environment that we live in and that we
don't really are not understanding well
enough the resilience that there is in a
democracy and how we do have to work
together so I am the way I describe
myself now I've been asked to describe
myself in six words and a worried
optimist a problem-solver and a grateful
American and that describes the kinds of
things that I'm doing in my life now
which I talk about in my book you also
talked about how you said resilience you
talked about how that is a
characteristic that has helped you
through your life and I think a lot of
people are trying to figure out that out
now like we're all going through a lot
as a country some of us a lot more than
others people have lost their job and
resilience how important is that it's
incredibly important and one of the
things and I write about this in my book
my parents
I actually am old enough that I was in
England during the war during the Blitz
with my parents I was a little girl and
they were forced to leave their country
live in pretty much seclusion in a
country where they didn't speak the
language and had no control because they
had no control over the bombs the only
thing they had control over was their
mood and I think that that's where we
are now we're not in control we need the
resilience to understand that we will
get through all this and then figure out
the ways that help us solve the problem
to work together and has made so much
difference in my life and
ever part of my life resilience has been
a crucial part of bouncing back you have
to bounce back one last story I wanted
you to tell you got pulled aside after a
long overnight flight by British customs
and they were giving you a hard time and
it was taking a long time to get out of
there tell me what happened in that line
it was very funny because there I am on
the floor taking everything out of my
suitcase and I never do this but I
finally said excuse me but do you know
who I am and the guy looked at me he
said no but we can find a doctor who can
help you figure it out and there was no
way to do anything but laugh at that and
so you've got to recognize that there's
no point in getting angry just laugh
that's right well hopefully he will see
your book and realize that oh that was
that lady that's who she was former
Secretary of State you an ambassador
diplomat to America and a proud American
thank you so much Madeleine Albright for
being on the show today Thank You Dana
stay well